bonsoir à tous merci pour l'accueil
parfois je me dis que dans quelques
décennies à les observateurs
caractériseront notre époque par une
forme de paresse est aux antipodes de la
paresse moi je vais vous parler de
quelque chose qui m'est cher parce que
je pense c'est le principal levier de
changement
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle aussi quelque
chose qui nous qui guide tous les
projets que nous réalisons avec le
collectif ou yes we can't say la
capacité collective
et puisque tout est permis à tête je
vais même essayer de vous en donner une
recette
donc ce soir une recette de capacité
collective avec un ingrédient principal
qui est le temps des gens on dit souvent
qu'on a plus beaucoup de temps je pense
qu'ils ont des zooms un peu c'est
structurellement pas vrai on vit plus
longtemps on étudie plus longtemps ni
retraités plus longtemps on a des
lave-vaisselle et lave-linge donc les
tâches domestiques prennent moins de
temps mais c'est pas tant le stock de
temps qui compte c'est là le temps qu'on
va les chercher
c'est un temps précieux c'est celui ont
fait le pari imaginez enfin notre vie à
chacun aujourd'hui c'est un cercle c'est
ce qu'on connaît c'est notre zone c'est
ce qu'ont fait chaque jour elle parie
qu'on peut faire c'est que nous tous
dans le ventre on a on est prêts à faire
davantage parce qu'on a envie finalement
de rencontrer des personnes qu'on ne
qu'on ne connaît pas apprendre des
choses qu'on ne maîtrise pas encore
c'est pas simple d'y arriver mais
l'envié est là et c'est ce temps là
qu'on serait prêts à rendre disponibles
que nous on va mettre dans la casserole
après le temps il ya l'espace pas
n'importe quel espace on va pas y mettre
une galerie commerçante par exemple on
va y mettre des espaces qui nous
inspirent des espaces qui dans un parfum
de liberté de possibilités
ceux qui ont grandi avec un terrain
vague pas très loin de chez eux voyez
bien de quoi je veux parler de l'espace
du temps les espaces de cette qualité on
en a
il y en a dans la nature une plage une
forêt y en a aussi en ville en fait ces
espaces là il existe dès qu'on met entre
parenthèses la mécanique de rentabilité
financière donc des friches des
bâtiments vacants ou à chaque fois qu'il
ya une opération d'urbanisme
il ya toujours des moments où les lieux
doivent être libérés pendant quelques
années
c'est cela sur lesquelles on va pouvoir
travailler ensuite on ajoute d'autres
composantes à notre casseroles on va y
mettre de la juxtaposition du panache et
la régie des possibles luc sa position
c'est le fait que dans ces espaces il
est structurellement des personnes
différentes des groupes sociaux
différents des des fonctions différentes
ça s'adresse les populations mobiles
comme vous pourront choisir d'aller dans
ces espaces mais les plus petits les
plus vieux les plus fragiles les plus
abîmés par la vie cela si on veut les
avoir il faut le choisir
dès le début le panache c'est le fait
que si on veut se mettre en capacité
individuellement collectivement un
moment va falloir bouger les lignes
va falloir changer ceux des cadres et se
décaler ce que savent très bien faire
les artistes je me souviens une fois je
vais tout coûté une conférence d'un
architecte s'appelait claude parent qui
trouvaient que à vivre dans des boîtes
rectangulaires on se rétrécissait on
aura beau crise et notre esprit et donc
il a dessiné toute sa vie des des
bâtiments des espaces à vivre avec des
obliques la régie des possibles le
bureau des possibles c'est de bien sûr
une fois qu'on commence à faire d'avoir
des outils d'avoir un outil des ateliers
de l'outillage des compétences à
disposition
on a nos ingrédients ensuite ce qui va
être important c'est la cuisson c'est la
fermentation
c'est la manière dont on va faire
prendre quelque chose entre ces éléments
qu'on nous avons mis au même endroit au
même moment
et c'est là où il faut la patience est
une forme de talent puisque aujourd'hui
on sait pas très bien faire il faut un
processus ouvert itératif le pire en
fait c'est de savoir exactement ce qu'on
veut d'avoir l'argent pour le faire
al'inverse si on sait à peu près où on
va mais on va prendre le temps
on va laisser faire vraiment laisser la
place pour que les choses soient
appropriés pour qu elles s'enchaînent
bloc par bloc
on aura on va pouvoir créer ce processus
itératif qui amène vers la capacité
collective
c'est assez nouveau puisque c'est au
al'inverse de la manière dont
aujourd'hui les entreprises ou les
institutions réalise des projets ils
veulent d'abord savoir ce qu'on va faire
pour appuyer sur le bouton go no go nogo
avec le feu vert parce qu'il faut
accepter une forme d'un détermination et
de lâcher prise sur la manière dont on
met en oeuvre un projet on va passer un
peu à la pratique illustré des exemples
de capacité collective avec peut-être le
plus beau des démonstrateurs aujourd'hui
un projet que nous avons baptisé les
grands voisins ça se passe ici l'espace
c'est un ancien hôpital dans un hôpital
saint-vincent-de-paul dans le 14ème à
paris espace rendus disponibles par le
jeu des transformations urbaines et de
l'arrivée d'un écoquartier disponible
pendant deux ans dans cet espace il ya
une dizaine de bâtiments quarante mille
mètres carrés c'est assez grand et il ya
aussi l'espace extérieur est ce qui est
intéressant c'est important tout cet
espace extérieur puisque entre les
points fixes que composent les bâtiments
c'est l'espace on va pouvoir travailler
toutes les interfaces voici l'espace la
juxtaposition l'a obtenue par un choix
structurelles dès le départ d'accueillir
sur ce site plusieurs foyers centre
d'hébergement social qui accueille des
personnes vulnérables des personnes qui
viennent de la rue des personnes un
foyer de travailleurs migrants
c'est l'association aurore qui est en
charge ces publics les 800 personnes
vulnérables qui vivent qui dorment tous
les jours sur le site des grands voisins
le deuxième point fixe c'est le choix
d'accueillir dans d'autres espaces de
l'hôpital des entreprises des
associations des start up
c'est 200 structures aujourd'hui qui
sont installés c'est une personne qui
viennent travailler
ils ont le choix a été fait avec
l'association plateau urbain ensuite on
organise beaucoup d'événements des
événements familiaux d'événements
pointue des concerts qui permettent
d'avoir du public on a aussi installé un
camping qui permet d'accueillir des
voyageurs venus souvent d'autres pays
voici la juxtaposition qu'on a
on a ajouté le panache a beaucoup
d'artistes sur site il ya des ateliers
municipaux mutualisé donc une régie des
possibles assez bien développé est ce
qu'il ya c'est beau et qui a confirmé
nos intuitions
c'est le déploiement dans cette
casserole des grands voisins du temps
des gens les sollicitations pour
intervenir dans le projet de manière
bénévole de manière volontaire était
bien supérieur à nos besoins hanoune à
l'esprit qu'en régie en a quarante
personnes tous les jours sur le site
finalement si bien qu'on a été source et
auprès des 200 autres structures savoir
qui elles pouvaient avoir besoin de ces
implication volontaire
donc c'est du temps de travail pour
oeuvrer avec les mains pour jardiner
pour bricoler c'est aussi du temps de
détente de partage de moments de
convivialité c'est aussi du temps pour
être ensemble en famille avec des amis
je vais pour terminer sur les grands
voisins je vais vous montrer trois
photos qui sont trois résultats
possibles de ce que peut rendre
accessible la capacité collective
la première ici c'est la notion
d'apprentissage croisé par l'ensemble de
ce qu'on a déployé sur cet espace on a
joué avec les curseurs de telle manière
à ce que les les positions de qui
apprenant qu'ils aient sachant qui est
celui qui sait qui est celui qui va
apprendre ont été ont été gommés toutes
ces personnes différentes qui cohabitent
qui sont en juxtaposition sur le site
peuvent en tout ca capacité d'apprendre
les uns aux autres
salif ici vient du burkina faso il
habite sur site au grand voisin et nous
avait bricolé nous a dit moi je vais
faire du métal si vous voulez on peut en
faire et depuis régulièrement il ya des
ateliers fonderie no ken micro fonderie
comme ça dans 14e une autre photo on est
en mars de cette année il pleut mais on
avait décidé que ce serait le carnaval
des grands voisins à cet endroit même
dix mois plus tôt c'est complètement
vide ses murs et ses gardienné
et ce jour là sous la pluie à 2000
personnes avec une quinzaine de chars
qui sont ont tous été fabriqués sur site
avec des matériaux trouvés sur site ou
qui nous arrive parce qu'on on accueille
des matériaux pour des seconds y est
tous les chars fait par les différents
groupes sociaux qui sont sur site les
héberger de l'association aurore les
entrepreneurs le public au delà de cette
voie là cette démonstration de force
collective quand on ne l'a suffit de le
décider n'y a pas eu de budget ça c'est
fait juste punta n'aimant pas ce que on
se l'est dit qu'on pouvait le faire ce
qu'il faut voir aussi derrière et qu'on
peut aussi voir quand on se promène
heures en semaine ou un dimanche et
qu'on voit tout le monde assis sur les
bancs c'est la notion dégâts légitimité
de tous ces groupes sociaux à être à
être là dans cet endroit il n'y a pas de
vent on veut on fait la juxtaposition
sans domination d'un groupe social sur
les autres et dernier point que je
voulais dire sur les grands voisins
cet espace extérieur cet espace
d'interface il n'est pas dans le
périmètre de la ville de paris y'a pas
de régie municipale tout le soin qui a
apporté le travail la botanique la
propreté le ménage les qualifications le
fab fabriquer des mobiliers s'est fait
de manière
pas spontanée parce que c'est encadré
mais s'est fait de manière organique sur
le site
donc si on réveille si on perd mais
cette capacité collective
on peut aller jusqu'à penser que tous
ces espaces qu'on partage chaque jour
peuvent être régies de manière
collective n'est pas que les grands
voisins pour montrer des exemples de
capacité collective c'est dans ma rue
avec un autre voisin con qui ne trouvait
pas non plus de place pour garer son
vélo le soir on a on sait déployer un
peu comme ça là vous gardez voiture et
c'est devenu l'endroit on peut garer les
vélos ici on est à rennes
c'est un projet qui s'appelle l'hôtel
pasteur un bâtiment près de la gare où
la vie qui appartient à la ville la
ville qui veut en faire un équipement
culturel ou chief les travaux ça coûte
10 million c'est cher comment on va
faire et là arrive une architecte qui
s'appelle sophie ricard un outil de 10
mois je vais je peux faire l'étude en
direct en usage de sept bâtiments
ça fait trois ans qu'elle est sur site
et tous les jours toutes les semaines
des l'espace les tous les étages de ce
bâtiment sur lequel il ya toujours pas
eu de travaux il ya pas de chauffage est
utilisé par des personnes par des
compagnies théâtre ils viennent répéter
par des groupes des entreprises ici
c'est une cérémonie de remise de
diplômes autre exemple toujours on est à
marseille ici c'était notre premier
projet yasuni campe sur ce sur un
terrain en béton qui appartient au port
on a raconté une histoire qu'on allait
fabriquer une une ville éphémère
généreuse artistique écologique
là encore par la force du récit par la
force des ingrédients de la capacité
collective des dizaines de constructeurs
sont venus de toute l'europe pour
fabriquer ce qui est devenu un endroit
assez cool comme ça pendant les quatre
mois de la capitale de la culture
ici on a aubervilliers quartier des
quatre chemins assez difficile une
friche fermée où les gens jettent leurs
poubelles par un travail
avec nos ingrédients de juxtaposition de
présence artistique rigide est possible
les habitants viennent et ensemble on a
ouvert sur tout pendant quatre mois
d'été cet espace comme un lieu de
convivialité
dernier exemple à nanterre en ce moment
où on a récupéré un terrain pour bruit
tant dans la zone d'expansion des gros
et on plante les arbres du futur
quartier
ça paraît ce sont des projets chouette
ce sont des projets festifs avec
beaucoup de moments de rencontre il ya
beaucoup d'épanouissement de ceux qui y
participent
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
assez sérieux aussi puisque cette ces
projets même plutôt cette démarche le
processus ouvert cette mise en capacité
collective agit comme un antidote à la
maladie principale qui mine notre époque
aujourd'hui cette maladie c'est la
fragmentation fragmentation sociale
fragmentation spatiale ça fait un moment
qu'on sépare tout à l'aide de la voiture
des supermarchés à l'aide aussi du
salariat quelque part peut-être même de
l'état providence à l'aide aujourd'hui
des téléphones smartphones des
désabonnements tout genre chacun se
retrouve dans sa case et on se rabougrit
un peu à nous coupe les bras cette
fragmentation elle se déploie elle crée
des sentiment de défiance très présents
aujourd'hui les uns envers les autres
des sentiments d'impuissance on a
l'impression qu'on n'est pas capable de
faire les choses parce qu'on n'aurait
pas le nez le niveau parce qu'on a peur
du jugement de l'autre sentiment dette
illégitime aussi avoir le droit de faire
des choses ce toutes ses composantes de
de la fragmentation on doit les
combattre ensemble chaque jour notre
manière à différentes échelles
ça se joue sajou au coin de la rue mais
c'est pas ce serait faux de ne retenir
que ça ce serait trop facile de dire que
ça dépend de chacun c'est un enjeu de
politique publique crédit public
aujourd'hui elle sait rester bien faire
des choses chères qui met longtemps à se
mettre en place
toute cette démarche plus ouverte où on
accepte de l'indéterminé mais qui va
utiliser les intéristes les interstices
des espaces des interstices de temps qui
existe dans nos vies à chacun c'est
cette politique publique qu'il faut
souhaiter en mise en place et on est à
la rencontre entre ce que aujourd'hui
cette démarche ni la paix de l'action
publique ni le marché ne savent la
produire elle a été produite par la
société civile on souhaite qu'elles
puissent se systématiser la bonne
nouvelle c'est que on voit partout ces
projets qui est un outil très puissant
c'est l'espace partagé l'espace
partagent l'espace l'aménagement de
l'espace façonnent notre attitude
intitulé individuel attitude collective
aujourd'hui si vous déplacez vous allez
prendre un train en gare saint lazare
j'allais partir traverser des espaces
partagés vous serez un citoyen régulé
qui va qui peut aller d'un endroit à un
autre
vous serez aussi quand vous passez
devant toutes les vitrines et les les
affiches publicitaires un client est ce
que vous ne serez pas et que vous êtes
dans les projets qu'on a montré ses
seins
quelqu'un qui peut s'investir qui peut
s'impliquer de manière plus ou moins
simple à plus ou moins long terme dans
ces espaces partagés
il suffit de peu de signaux pour rendre
cette capacité collective
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'on
fait système al'inverse de cette
fragmentation avoir retrouvé ou avoir
déployé la conviction qu'on et
interdépendants les uns des autres avec
nous les 9 milliards d'êtres humains sur
cette planète terre nous et les autres
animaux une chorégraphe une fois elle
m'a dit faut pas dire les animaux faut
lire les autres animaux si on comprend
qu'on fait ce système on sera à agir et
l'a finalement et j'en conclus avec ça
l'enjeu l'enjeu ce sont nos choix et
plus exactement c'est la fabrication de
nos choix
aujourd'hui on est tous là en fin de
chaîne dans la production des choix les
choix se existe ailleurs son produit
ailleurs et on peut ils sont souvent
binaire d'ailleurs je like the light pas
j'achète j'achète pas comme si je vote
comme ça
l'enjeu si on avait que 7 euros ces
recettes d'après à 2 go de capacité
collective c'est de remonter la chaîne
est d'être capable de coproduire les
vents la matrice des choix l'éventail
des choix et à cette condition je crois
qu'on sera capable de beaucoup on sera
incapable d'agir face à face aux défis
de notre époque que sont le changement
du climat et que sont la part
d'hospitalité de l'altérité la place
qu'on fait aux autres merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]